deux secondes c'est squeeze aujourd'hui
on se trouve sur leurs think est un jeu
d'horreur mais pas comme tous les autres
jeux de mots rares jeunes aura assez
amusant et original plein le petit
battement de coeur qui tenait pas très
bien d'entrée de jeu parce qu'on n'a pas
dans une chambre d'hôpital bien vide ma
foi juste ça pour s'occuper une sorte
d'écran de 2 pouces et demi c'est parti
voilà c'est là qu'on entend dans
l'original quand je vous disais en fait
comme vous pouvez le voir on envoie des
sortes d'autres d'onde qui nous font
voir ce qui est autour de nous et pour
voir loin d'après ce que j'ai compris il
faut qu'on balance des objets voilà on a
absolument aucun objet ça c'est fermé
voyez déjà un truc sans voix millions
d'ha la seconde calmez vous ah si ok
voilà ok donc c'est là qu'on dégage au
caire où est ce qu'on est
mais [ __ ] qu'est ce moment passé pts
qui vous a engagé bordel c'est carrément
mal votre travail scandaleux
qu'est ce que c'est que ça audio log ok
d'accord on voit carrément bien autour
de nous oh oui magnifique tu te tais tu
fis dans lavabo sous l'eau allez ça
suffit donc là je pense c'est par là
haut ou qui s milliards c'est un méchant
c'est un gentil c'est un gentil c'est
peut-être le dentiste finalement qui n'a
pas les clefs de son propre cabinet
c'est triste pour toi mon gars crois moi
que je vais pas d'ouvrir mais il me fait
super peur alors je pas qu'il ya pas mal
gré c'est ça marche il est déjà plus là
auquel elle est dedans non le mec qui
jouent à chat mais qui est carrément
relou gaillacois waouh ça marche il ya
de quoi faire un bon gros attentat
attendez je peux pas faire quelque chose
avec je voyais déjà faire une méga expo
où ça c'est rouge as assez méchant ça au
lac étals au hockey je dis plus jamais
au lac et talent ça marche on reste aux
français à nathan il colle à la vite mon
gars mais voilà et oui colavitti il m'a
valu tranquillement dans cette aide
publique qu'on a le jeu vous êtes passés
là haut où s'étend du quai on n'a rien
ôté les iem portes qui ne s'ouvrent à
jamais mais non mais non mais quel est
son pouvoir de faire passer à travers
les barreaux monga ou alors on est
extrêmement maigre je pense qu'on
extrêmement maigres ambitions en f1
comme manon sont en effet comment on
peut pas passer a trait à la barre ou
puisqu'ils peuvent pas bon bref ça
suffit on n'est pas là pour créer une
dissertation philosophique ou sur les
magnétos s'il vous plaît le wedding vous
entendez et du rouge au fond attendez là
j'ai l'impression avec des ondes quoi ça
pas du tout déjà il y avait un mec dans
une chambre qui était pas gentil du tout
en we made it ou il ment il se mange ses
branches en trop rien d imanche
carrément les fesses alors il aime le
pantalon je sais pas ce qu'ils mangent
quitte à manger les vêtements mangent
les quand quelqu'un de les portes pare
balles et par là ça semble extrêmement
pas bon
oh non mais non non je bouge plus haut à
à atépa fut tout accomplir mon gars un
imbécile
c'est pour ça qu'on prie passez à
kouroussa couples les pl et pire à la
panique
je dois être meilleur que le caleçon de
l'autre comment je vous ça cet ascenseur
là je ne peux pas mais non
l'ascenseur est arrivé je n'ai entendu
fêter ça lui fait du sud attention c'est
bon mais pourquoi j'ai la pression sur
les jeux comme ça [ __ ] ça les connaît
quoi bien toujours aux démineurs
j'aurais peur comme une bombe explosera
c'est n'importe quoi
l'armée lui il est gentil il est pas
rouge donc les mois il est gentil il n'a
jamais mangé de caleçons encore elle
n'est pas contaminée et tranquille aux 1
carrément des ovnis qui joignent à nous
comme ça tranquillement et mangeurs de
vêtements ne suffisent plus ça y est up
est à brax c'est mon cassoulet sam est
tellement la pression au real c'est un
truc de dingue
sans déconner en regardez là de quoi
faire un super alors soit c'est moi de
gaz soit des bouteilles de 5 litres
d'eau bon auquel cas c'est beaucoup
moins offensif voire même inutile au
sahel a attiré salle à attirer les
revend les rues nous tu ne peux pas
mourir mais cassoulet un plat de
lentilles jeu c'est pas un truc plus
tard avec toi t'as plein de concerts
promettent mange pas les concernent
préfère ma vallée moi [ __ ] t'es une
bouche comme ça je suis comme ça y'a pas
moyen de désactiver un truc là n'ont
absolument pas ta je me croyais dans
dans 007 coupé tester tout ça sert à
rien puisqu'on fait déjà dans le noir
qui est vite vite
auj là bas il arrivait un mois ils
arrivèrent nous ils arrivèrent nous il
m'a vu coup hop là c'est là bas c'est
une diversion de type 5 litre d'eau sous
la porte
non non mais non mais non 5 litre d'eau
c'est mieux pour toi que de la chair
humaine chuter sioniste un peu dans la
vie je me connais tu sais non non je te
jure sellem burger et maddy lacroix
annonce quoi tu te plais moi je voulais
pas mais il va forcer c'est pas de ma
fille c'est vrai mais c'est quoi c'est
dû tous les boîtes de quoi mon gars
tomates
allez c'est parti un cours de cuisine
avec toi mon ami on y va on y va aller
on fait un petit marathon en même temps
bah oui qui dit cuisine 10.10.10 grosse
des grossesses gros pardon équilibre au
10 sport je dis n'importe quoi parce que
j'ai peur
enfin papa
pas un papa allez on a réussi à huy
quittez pas si mauvaise cours de cuisine
alors qu'est-ce que s'esquisse à
lesneven château maintenant
tranquillement mais moi je veux aller
dans ceux de or dans ce merveilleux
dehors à ça ça veut dire non non non ça
peut même dire va te faire en langage
déroberons pas des portes là un truc
ok nickel tout est sur une réserve vide
y a plus aucune concerne c'est peut-être
de ma faute tout ce que j'ai utilisée
pour faire mon cours de cuisine et de
tout à l'heure mais bon il me faut une
carte pour pouvoir passer pour pouvoir
ouvrir la porte à l étage bien
évidemment l étage où il y aura le
propriétaire de la maison qui est un
mangeur de caleçon calme-toi calme-toi à
l'homme du magnéto j'ai déjà la pression
je pas besoin de ça et c'est que ça une
corde de pour nous annoncer non plus
très bien qui est encore j'ai la clé
s'est passé quoi là il ya des zones
rouges vient de tomber nez à nez
salut cours de cuisine [ __ ] ils pas
intéressés choix me cacher dans une
armoire
non on n'est pas dans le classement
howie va là dedans et enferme toi moi
même fait à toilettes on va les coûts
auger gérer ma part père et lui apporte
perello content et je m'enfuis ta maison
mon gars comme what toi
mais pourquoi il s'est pas levée je sais
pas n'importe quelle histoire du monde
tu reste appuyé sur le bouton ce truc
m'a dit d'aller me faire [ __ ] puis
ensuite faut que je fasse ça dessus en
boucle pour que ça se lève quoi le
scandale est quand même on n'est pas les
bons agent secret son icône est
franchement devrait être employé par le
fbi ou par par quelque chose quoi même
en tant que concierge dans un collège
c'est pas grave vous serez les agents
secrets allez mon gars mellouk est
vivant il y va il va regarder en
peignoir comme ça tranquillement hiva oa
là bas olam une forme de dengue qui t'a
il n'a pas aimé qu'on s'engueule de son
peignoir au je te déteste comme en
peignoir va là bas tu entends pas le
magnéto mon gars c'est un vrai concert
j'en ai marre avoir ta langue tu as là
j'avais réussi quoi pourquoi la grille
elle est si vilaine pour la punir cette
grille sérieusement voilà transformé en
je sais pas en bas et je sais pas moi
voilà comme ça on l'avait dans un autre
poète ça vient plus à rien le frh et
plus personne au nom mais va là bas j'ai
mis trop loin de lui reçoit pas les
ondes mais j'ai dit oui
le screamer il attendait en peignoir
devant la porte toi bien mélissa dit ils
sont tous on va y arriver
faites moi confiance voilà ok valeur
faciale en phase iv en face il valait en
face il va aller en face va aller en
face ils allaient en face de moi
malheureusement je ne baisserai pas les
bras
où est passé l'enregistrement une pac
qui vient là non payées temps mais tu
t'es pris un coup de micro sur la tête
et sur cette mort quoi c'est le commerce
appellent à micro ondes un va moi non
plus faudrait ok j'ai une des jeunes des
camps il va venir là il va rentrer dans
un truc
ok oui ça oui patience est mère de
toutes les victimes et des fautes et
tout je sais qui est juste derrière
je le sais je le vois je le sens en plus
j'ai fait l'objet a balancé à micro
ondes
ça va marcher
je fais une technique trop bien là le
mec qui fait des demi-tours
tranquillement c'est pas pourquoi est ce
que le regard regarder à ses pieds et
voilà il se dit bon fichier plus on est
nuls un jeu je suis de leur jeu c'était
le cri du désespoir ça j'achèterai plus
jamais de peignoir par ta faute mon gars
rentrent ok on la ferme
ballester jetant fermer mon gars
allaient l'était pas chier fais pas
chier fais pas chier on l'avait fait
mais il était là avec son peignoir
il pleurait dans son peignoir comme ses
sushis mais bon sang mais en fait
j'aurais pu passer trait à la grille
j'ai attendu beaucoup tonton on la
refait ans la fin ok ça marche et ça
marche et ça a marché
gelée rouverte géraud vertu trop con
basse et ouvre toi mon gars aux toits la
bande à babré ballon bas ça fait quoi
d'être bloquée chez soi ah parce que tu
sais au gré des pentes us et chasser un
mec tranquillement chez toi mais tu est
pas foutu tacopina à ça fait du bien
liberté vient ça moi et me dites pas que
dans ce décor sans bruit il ya des
monstres comme ça une autre pièce que je
ne sens pas du tout ah non c'est bon et
nous voyons dans notre chambre du début
pour recommencer un coup fantastique
leur king on a fini le jeu mesdames et
messieurs spectacle rare incroyable et
ben c'était bien sympa comme concept si
ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas aimé le prochain épisode
de joséphine ange gardien reste à vous
regarder cette vidéo on se retrouve très
vite dans ce domaine vidéo tient tout le
monde bis